I've known you a long time I've always
known that you're a very beautiful
person but you don't like to work out
you don't work at it no I don't you
don't you don't like it and you've never
liked it it's not like you to dislike it
you never liked working yeah that's
right I hate it because well and I did
try because I thought I should have a
trainer you know and I started doing
friends and I should you know work at
this and I just kept getting hurt I
don't like what am i doing
her dinner oh no you work through the
pain it's like none of the pain is a
sign that you're about to injure
yourself you know work through it you
pay heed you must pay heed you must
honor your pain your pain with heed I
couldn't think of what to say so I went
back I see you went back into olden
times my curious I don't like you you
had good trainers because I don't think
I had the best you had them I never
telling you plant just go through the
pain
yeah work through the pain and then so
then the next day I can't walk or
something in it for like weeks it hurts
like yeah yeah that's good it's okay
it's not I don't think it is okay we're
you were somewhat athletic I think you
play tennis and yeah I got hurt you
never got hurt then no so then you're
this really successful actress you're an
adult you're working on this huge hit
massive show you get a trainer why were
you suddenly getting hurt all the time
because the trainer's hurt me I'm trying
to say I know because I'm older I don't
know what do you think no no I was just
going well I know it's on me I think
it's your fault that's what that's where
I'm going I know a weak person you know
I mean I am cautious anyway yes I was
gonna say that that you are a cautious
person who may start to feel like ah I
don't know how much pain I'm just being
really honest here I don't know how much
real pain maybe there was a little bit
of a jab you were like let's be careful
let's give heed to the situation
that's why I'm going with it yeah but no
I wasn't being overly cautious I it was
like almost a tear in something yeah I
don't know I've got doctors in my family
they would say like oh yeah well then
for God's sake stop yeah yeah yeah okay
doing that again yeah I mean I don't
know I just well you know I'm I am
afraid of getting really hurt you know I
stopped skiing like 10 years ago because
everyone gets hurt you know what is true
I last couple of people I've talked to
who have gone skiing all say the same
thing they've been skiing all their life
and then they're going down a hill and I
always ask what happened like did you
hit a root did you hit a tree at someone
else hit you and they say no I was
skiing along I've had like three people
tell me this and then I just heard a pop
in my knee that's when my leg fell off
right I'm not talking to healthy people
they're there and they're holding their
leg they've got it it's ridiculous and I
don't know what happens I it's dangerous
yeah that's what happens it's really do
you like throwing yourself down a hill
ok does it be faster than our legs can
actually take us ok it's called Age 2
we're old well I'm not but you're right
I mean you can't do the things that you
did when you were 25 and I couldn't do
the more 25 that's the other point I
couldn't take him at 25 I couldn't do
any of those things I was hearing
popping and things were snapping and
breaking right when I was 19 years old I
bet we'll you seemed kind of like loose
well you know it's like when women get
wouldn't get pregnant it's like when
women get pregnant right like tendons so
Bennett's really yes about yes I'm very
much like a pregnant woman estrogen has
been released in my body and I've gotten
all loose and floppy not you're pregnant
yeah I think you have the hormones mixed
up okay no I actually have them just
right